As an entrepreneur when you're
looking at your product and
you're trying to determine whether
an MVP is good enough, and
whether you have to reach your product
perfection before you can go out to
customers, some of this depends on
what customers you initially go after.
And as an entrepreneur,
part of being an entrepreneur is
maybe selecting the right
customers out of the gate.
Can you find customers who are willing
to take something that's not
quite finished and
provide valuable feedback?
Are they willing to take something and
incorporate it into their business?
Those are the first
customers that you want.
Because some customers on
the other hand might tell you,
we don't want to try this or use it in
our business until it's completely done
and it's out in the marketplace.
And if those are your
initial set of customers,
then the bar is too high
before you can get feedback.
And so part of figuring out what that
MVP is, is actually figuring out who
your first customers are and selecting
the right set of first customers.